what was your was your mind i'm just
walking away because i just
i want openness and i want honesty and i
just don't feel like
you know sometimes your demeanor is very
closed off and you know that's
not a very healthy relationship
you meet my friends you meet my eggs
i'm always oh i did it for clarity
because
you know
i don't want roundabout answers to be
honest with you and you know she
answered
i don't think octavia made anything up
that she told me but on the other hand i
want to give georgie the benefit of the
doubt but it's just really hard to
believe everything that he he says
i'm not chasing a man
i want my fiance to come to me i want to
feel loved i want to feel embraced
i want to feel all the feelings that you
get to feel from me
i want to give you love
but sometimes
you're kind of pushing me away with
your insecurities you're questioning
your your your trust issue always show i
never do something to make you feel that
you cannot trust me i get divorced i
think after this you're going to trust
me that's your decision you were already
separated i'm not talking about this
you're talking you just thinking talk
about something you don't get the point
you never get the point
the fact that he always blames me makes
me feel like it's always my fault
i don't want to feel like that
i just keep giving so much and it's like
why should i have to feel that way
i love you
i really feel that i love you
okay but i feel like
i need to honor who i am as a woman
and
i don't feel like at times i'm feeling
your commitment
openly and honestly and emotionally
and
until i do feel those things from you
i don't want you to come back to
connecticut
[Music]
you